В Україні цього тижня почалося часткове послаблення карантину.
Але повноцінну роботу громадського транспорту так і не відновлено.
Оглядачі критикують владу за повне "відключення" на час пандемії
метрополітену в Києві та іншого транспорту.
Адже практично скрізь у світі громадський транспорт
навіть у період жорстких обмежень продовжував працювати.
Зокрема й у Німеччині.
Це Бонн на Заході Німеччини,
місто з населенням 300 тисяч осіб.
Багато закладів і надалі не працюють,
але дехто поспішає у справах.
Два місяці в салонах автобусів і трамваїв
панував штиль, пригадують пасажири.
Якийсь час було дещо менше, але тепер знову стає більше
Так, стало краще. Раніше треба було затискуватися.
І це було неприємно. Особливо у ранкові години.
Робота громадського транспорту у Німеччині
в часи коронавірусу регламентована низкою правил.
Одне з них - пасажирам обов'язково носити захисну маску.
І тримати відстань у 1,5 метра.
Як бачимо, боннські пасажири поводяться дисципліновано.
А Ви не повинні носити маску?
Входити до автобусу через передні двері повз водія не можна.
Передню частину салону відгородили від решти спеціальною плівкою.
Цей простір - виключно для водія.
Зазвичай у німецьких автобусах є спеціальні кнопки для відчинення дверей -
пасажир сигналізує, що хоче вийти на наступній зупинці.
Від цієї "фішки" на тлі епідемії відмовилися -
аби зменшити загрозу передачі вірусу через пальці рук.
Тепер двері відчиняються
на кожній зупинці автоматично.
Автобуси й трамваї тепер ретельно миють
дезінфікуючими засобами щовечора в кінці зміни.
Стало помітно охайніше й на зупинках,
їх теж регулярно дезінфікують.
Квитків за проїзд водії більше не продають.
Квиткові автомати працюють, як раніше.
Утім, пасажирам настійливо рекомендують
купувати квитки безконтактно -
через мобільний додаток.
А контролерам заборонено доторкатися
до квитків або смартфонів пасажирів.
Ці санітарні заходи у Бонні
запровадили ще в березні,
на початку жорстких обмежень.
Тому громадський транспорт у місті не припиняв працювати,
хоч і за скороченим графіком.
А ось маршрути у напрямку клінік
стали ходити навпаки - утричі частіше.
Одночасно в місті розширили альтернативні сервіси.
Наприклад, можна без зайвих клопотів
узяти напрокат велосипед або скутер.
А власникам місячних проїзних квитків
надали можливість тимчасово не сплачувати абонемент.
Але чи не страшно пасажирам заразитися в трамваї чи автобусі,
особливо у години пік?
Ні. З моєю захисною маскою
я сприймаю це позитивно.
Інакше мені зовсім не вийти з квартири.
Знаєте, треба якось гнати такі думки від себе,
інакше все життя буде перевернуте на 180 градусів
і вже не приноситиме радості.
Я помічаю, що багато літніх людей -
я навіть їм прямо звертала на це увагу - мали б одягати маски.
Ми, водії, боїмося заразитися. Справді.
Слава Богу, трохи захищені плівкою.
До речі, водії у Німеччині під час пандемії належать
до так званих критично важливих професій.
Вони мають право віддавати дітей у так звані "чергові групи" у дитсадках -
на рівні з медпрацівниками, продавцями, вчителями, журналістами тощо.
Для інших категорій дитсадки в Німеччині досі закриті на карантин.
З травня німецький транспорт запрацював у повному обсязі,
за графіками, як до коронавірусу.